how will you honor Lisa here because
when you come here you do such a great
job of honoring Elvis how will you honor
Lisa you know it's about celebrating her
life you know this whole Graceland is
about celebrating Elvis's life
and we're going to do the same for Lisa
the one thing you know she had many
thoughts about what her funeral would be
like there was no question she wanted to
be buried at Graceland
since her son passed away there was no
question she wanted to be married next
to her son
and the one thing she said is just don't
make it sad
um so she wanted to be a celebration she
wants to be a celebration and that's
what's going to be the myths that are
out there right now that there is some
kind of battle over this house is there
a secession plan there absolutely is
there was since Elvis you know when
Elvis before Elvis passed away he wanted
to make sure that Lisa Marie got the
home got the estate it was put into a
trust that trust throughout the years
have been updated and it was Lisa's
desire
without question that her children take
over Riley at this point because Riley
is of age majority and one day Harper
and Finley as well
it's their home it's their home it's
always been it's Elvis's home it's
Lisa's home it will be Riley's home
without question there is no court
battle
if there was I don't see how is there
anything else out there being said that
you want to dispel or just get to the
bottom of you know it's Lisa's intent
without question has been for Riley to
take over for her to have the twins
eventually take over for her be with
Riley there's no question in anyone's
mind that that was it that's where she
was that's what she wanted
and that's it since Benjamin passed away
she has struggled how was she that last
week it was by far the best week of her
life since Benjamin passed she was happy
I was with her for several days at
Graceland leading up to her dad's
birthday on the Sunday the 8th she had a
great time she stood for hours after the
ceremony signing autographs taking
photos she wouldn't leave until the last
person was satisfied she had an amazing
time we flew back right after we're
going to Los Angeles because Warner
Brothers was having a birthday party at
the Formosa
for the movie and to obviously for the
Oscars and she had an amazing time with
her with her daughter made it Austin was
there baz was there just a great time
she was looking forward to the Golden
Globes she had an amazing time at the
Golden Globe she was so happy that
Austin won it really you know she's you
know you know as she said she said I'm
gonna I'm gonna eat my foot if Austin
loses and she's just wanted Austin and
her have such a great relationship they
did an amazing interview together they
formed just a great Bond
she just was so thrilled at the
performance
[Music]
[Applause]
tell me about the bond between Lisa and
Austin because that was a person
embodying her father you know my
interactions with Lisa and during my
years with Lisa
she's always suspicious about everything
she was there were so many things that
went wrong in her life so many things
that didn't go the way they should
that she was very careful and cautious
about letting baz make the movie about
having Austin be in the movie
but when they got together they were
really Kindred Spirits you know Austin
had done such a great job over many
years you know kovid actually allowed
Austin to live in Elvis for so much
longer than he normally would have
that he really became Elvis and I think
Lisa saw that and Lisa was so proud and
she was so honored and you know again
Lisa is just you know her gut reaction
is not to do anything but when we talked
to her and we walked through and how
important it was to do an interview with
Austin and Austin took such great care
he really he understood her
vulnerability he saw uh you know that
she was a very vulnerable person which
she always was
it was just it was one of the most
amazing electric energetic and every
time I saw them together afterwards it
was so easy it was so just it was so
real you talked about Austin coming here
to Graceland tell me about that because
he his first visit was here to Graceland
his first visit very shortly after he
being named Elvis he came to Graceland
he really walked through he really
revered he took such you know it was so
serious to him it was so important to
him that he really his first experience
as was his first experience
the way you start the process is you
come here because when you come here it
all becomes clear
um
he has still he it feels like to me he
still has Elvis left inside him do you
see that you know I was I was with him
when he was the host of Saturday Night
Live uh and it was a little interesting
how he had to come in and out of it I
think it was much easier for him to come
into it than to come out of it you
talked about your relationship with Lisa
Marie what didn't we know about Lisa
Marie what did we understand
you know there's so many people who talk
about so many things about Lisa she was
just a kind earnest
just the realest person you would ever
meet you know my respect for her was
really about how real she was if she was
unhappy you knew about it if she was
happy you knew about it she was
brilliant she was an amazing performer I
was lucky enough I was actually the last
one to record Lisa we produced a gospel
record
and we did it and she performed a duet
with her dad
[Music]
she broke down halfway through the song
in the booth we recorded it in the same
studio in Hollywood that her dad
recorded the audio tracks for the 68
special so there's so much history there
and halfway through when she was really
she was singing to her father
she really became so emotional but she
was just you know she was one of the
most kind Earnest Souls I've ever met in
my life
this was her house and there was still
the private area upstairs but she would
come back and would she stay or just
have dinners no no this was her home and
you know early on you know I I have
known Lisa for about 10 years early on
for me
she would stay in the house she would
stay in the home she'd stay at home over
extended periods especially if something
wasn't going well in her life and this
wasn't her house this was her home you
know so this is you know this is 25
million people I visited Graceland it's
their house Elvis was theirs Elvis would
invite people in he would invite people
up
but this has really only been two
people's homes it's been Elvis's home
and it was Lisa's home so she would stay
here
when she was here what was that like
you know for me I I can't speak to other
people but for me it was it was great
because she was home it was something
that she felt so close to she would be
brought things
from her childhood that she didn't even
remember she would open up a box of
things that her dad a makeup kit that
her dad would take with her and there
would be so many memories in there that
it was truly it was it was an honor and
a privilege to watch her have those
memories and have those emotions
how hard was that to deal with when you
learned of her passing it's still to an
extent not real I mean I I was here 50
feet away
with Lisa two weeks ago
and to think about her just not being
here
and to having to interact with her and
just like I and many other people have
been able to visit with Ben I know that
every single time I come to this
property for the rest of my life I'm
going to visit with Lisa um
um we still see that people are coming
to tour and there will always be this
love for this place will there be any
special new Lisa Marie features or
anything added now to honor her you know
there's always been or for the last
number of years an exhibition for Lisa
and
really just an incredible moment is when
we showed Lisa the exhibition before it
opened uh there was a quote from her dad
that you know the best thing that he
ever did was her
and she had never seen that quote before
and it was such it she didn't know he
said it wasn't aware of it
and even that was so emotional and I'm
afraid to even walk in there right now
because of how emotional I would get
but it gave her great joy Graceland
gives people great joy so we're not
thinking about this from a business
standpoint I'm sure at some point we
will think about what we can do more for
Lisa here
but everything now is just to it is to
honor her and to celebrate her what will
Lisa Marie's Legacy be
you know she was an amazing performer
her records are great and I think she
wasn't given the chance to to perform
more to be more of who she was because
she was Elvis's child you know there are
some people who are not talented who are
who are leaning off their parents this
was exactly the opposite she was
unbelievably when you when you feel he
and hear the passion in her voice I
don't think she was given a chance and I
think in many ways in life she wasn't
given that chance so I think as time
goes on she's going to be a great
performer and she's also going to be the
person who you know she was selfless in
what she did for her dad every time
every decision that was made had nothing
to do with what's best for Lisa but
what's best for Elvis
foreign